even though Pokemon Go has broken
download records and attracted more
players than any app in recent history
it didn't take long for that fan fervour
to die down as frustrations with the
game have risen from not delivering on
promises to outright cutting out vital
parts of the game here are a few reasons
once dedicated players have turned
against Pokemon go the 3-step bug
when Pokemon go launched the game
included a feature that allowed players
to locate nearby Pokemon with some
accuracy which was in line with the apps
advertising instead of making players
wander aimlessly hoping for a random
encounter the game made it so little
monsters in your vicinity would show up
in a pop-up grid indicating their
distance from you before long this
feature stopped working giving players
no clue at all about where to find that
elusive Snorlax that might be fine for a
gameboy game but not so much for the
real world
as of the making of this video the
feature has not returned we've developed
a Niantic saying that it put too much
strain on the game's server's Terms of
Service because the game's tracking was
busted a website called pokévision
emerged to help find nearby Pokemon even
though the site broke my antics terms of
service by data mining to locate Pokemon
it provided an extremely useful tool to
make up for the missing feature
unfortunately after a few weeks Niantic
forced pokévision to shut down this was
a breaking point for many players who
weren't shy about voicing their
frustration the developers later
explained in a blog post that the data
scraping was still straining their
servers and preventing them from
launching in more countries so everyone
basically had to take one for the team
the update around this time Niantic also
pushed a small update to the game but
rather than fixing any outstanding bugs
like the app constantly freezing or it's
inaccurate GPS Niantic only made minor
cosmetic changes and completely removed
the game's tracking ability angry users
started contacting the app stores
refunds and Niantic became more hated
than mr. mime pokemons number-one crime
against nature
players speculated that the minor
updates were done only to bury the apps
one-star rating as some online stores
only
like the ratings the Nats most recent
version a slight change to the games
code and Niantic wiped the slate clean
eventually tracking was kind of replaced
allowing players to find Pokemon based
on local poker stops but it still wasn't
the same micro transaction manipulation
one game update also conveniently
included a bug that may Pokemon harder
to capture some players denied that the
game had increased in difficulty though
seeing a lowly Caterpie swat away a
perfect fro implied otherwise Niantic
confirmed the bug but did not
immediately offer a solution because it
didn't really do much more than make
players purchase more items from the
game store with trust between players
and Niantic already shaken many
speculated that the change wasn't a bug
at all but Niantic purposely gaming the
system to make more money no reply
players tried to contact my antic for
solutions but discovered that the email
address the developer had provided for
customer support wasn't being monitored
reddit users coordinated masses of
people in the Pokemon go community to
contact Apple and Google and let them
know about my antics Terms of Service
violations tips were dropped about how
to successfully request refunds and my
antic came under full attack by a user
base that had become upset with a game
that was totally breaking down shut it
down by now Niantic had received
complaints about certain locations not
being appropriate for Pokemon go use
from personal residences to a Holocaust
Museum players started to see the first
big wave of polka stop closures which
became apparent when Niantic started
shutting down polka stops at children's
hospitals where the game had become
especially popular players guessed that
the game's augmented reality features
could be a violation of HIPAA
regulations but that didn't do much to
quell the disappointment of the
countless kids who no longer had an
available gym or polka stop once the
darling of the App World Niantic had
entered a PR nightmare worse the most
seizure inducing porygon episodes we now
return to battling seizure robots
winter is coming Pokemon go is skewed
towards urban players since that's where
Pokemon spawn most often so for many
rural players catching monsters as a car
passenger was really the only option to
safely build an army of V's despite my
antics on-screen warnings to never use
the app while driving further updates
completely removed the ability to catch
anything at driving or even biking
speeds for people without sidewalks and
kids on long boring car rides the game
was essentially killed
and even though Niantic had already lost
a record number of players those numbers
will continue to drop during the colder
weather since no one will want to take
off their gloves to catch another dumb
Pidgey terrible gps one of pokemon goes
more rewarding features is the ability
for players to hatch eggs by walking
large distances not only just the
feature really get people outside and on
their feet but it also promises better
Pokemon for your efforts that is it
would if the game's GPS worked
consistently Niantic continues to
struggle with mapping players walking
distances accurately with many players
reporting that fewer than half of their
steps have been trapped after a hike
with the GPS repeatedly cutting out and
disconnecting players have become
disinclined to make the effort at all
the Pokemon go plus wristband was
supposed to change that however plus
disappointment when Pokemon go plus
finally came out it just didn't work as
players hope when the + lights up
players can tap the center button to
either catch a pokemon or snag goods
from a pokey stop unfortunately you
don't really have a choice about which
of these two things you can do if
there's a wild pokemon nearby the plus
has to catch it before you can access
any pokey stops
additionally the plus will only use
regular pokeballs and not your fancy
high-yield balls and players report that
the catch rate is far lower than what
you'd get if you just use the app
leaving many players coming up
empty-handed you also can't use any
items that would make Pokemon capture
easier and that's not all you'll still
need to be running the battery draining
app on your
the battery of the plus is not
rechargeable and the accessory will
constantly disconnect from your phone
you also can't catch types that you
haven't already caught you may as well
just use your phone or just like give up
completely no legendary events anyone
still playing is holding out for another
undelivered promise from the games
commercials legendary events even though
players still can't directly battle one
another or even trade Pokemon like
civilized human beings everyone still
wants to be able to catch your a Mewtwo
or a Zapdos Niantic decided to run a
Halloween themed event to tide people
over and even managed to draw back in
players would put the game aside but
they've made no statements about
releasing any legendary Pokemon into the
wild until then it's just a handful of
people catching the same things over and
over until everyone finally moves on to
the next game or just back to trading
pokemon cards ready to be the ultimate
pokemon master trainer yes I think I am
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know if you're still
playing Pokemon go